to go to college or not go to college
that is the question in the game of life
and I'm going to show you the data so
that you can make your own decision and
at the very end I'll give you my honest
advice and so let's talk about
playing the game of one of zero every
time I make a point for college I'm
going to move my college graduate
forward one point and every time I make
a point for my non- college graduate
I'll move him forward in his career one
point let's see who wins in the end this
chart shows you how much the cost of
going to college has gone up compared to
the starting salaries now you might be
like wow okay there is a big difference
here to put this tuition increase in
context this has doubled in just the
last few decades whereas the median
starting salary has more or less stayed
the same so you pay twice as much for
the same thing let me show you what the
result of this has been this is national
student loan debt and you're like oh
it's measured in dollarss that's in
trillions
1.76 trillion is more GDP than every
country in the world besides maybe the
top 10 so that means that our College
days kids young adults are taking on
more debt than entire nations produce
and so at some point you have to think
are they going to be able to make that
up and if you're a parent or loving
relative that a young person who's
making this decision is sent to I want
to talk to you specifically I went to
Vanderbilt which is a very good school
right now I think it's ranked 13 that's
tied with brown as a pseudo ivu League
school I graduated in three years magnet
klow I was president of my fraternity I
was vice president of the powerlifting
team and I did it in three then I went
into a white collar job management
consulting for two years and then while
I was at that job I studied very hard
and got above Harvard Business school's
GMAT midore and so that was my plan
until I started thinking a little bit
more for myself about wait does the math
really make sense here fast forward a
decade I now want a portfolio of
companies that does over $200 million a
year and I make these videos so that
hopefully younger people or just people
at different stages in their career can
make better picks and so that's my
formal education side my informal
education side is that I quit my white
collar job started at minimum wage at a
gym where I paid a guy to let me work
for him and follow him around all day
then I got into the gym business scaled
that to 5,000 locations in the US and
there a company called gym launch and I
sold that to private Equity Group for
46.2 million I now own
a portfolio of companies that has over a
thousand employees and so I know what
businesses today are actually looking
for and it's not what I used to think
and maybe what you used to think years
ago which is no one even looks at where
you went to school or what you majored
in or even what your GPA was all we care
about is your experience and the
likelihood that you can do the job well
and many of the jobs that are available
today there is no school for because the
school degrees and the things that they
taught have nothing to do with how much
the economy has changed and I know you
care a lot about whoever you're helping
make this decision I I want you to know
I care just as much and I don't benefit
from either of these decisions that they
choose to make except for maybe if they
do something that adds benefit to the
workforce they might eventually work at
one of my companies but that's really it
and so I make this as even-handedly as I
can because I benefited from both sides
and here's one of the worst Parts about
this debt number one is that the
interest rates are high and number two
is that you literally can't bankrupt out
of it meaning once you do this you're
stuck paying it for the rest of your
life I think that's one point for not
going to college now what do you
actually get when you pay for college
this is the median lifetime earnings by
education level meaning if you stop at
this level of Education this is how much
you can expect to make over the rest of
your career and so if you don't graduate
high school you make less than a million
dollars for the rest of your life that's
the median the middle person in the
range now if you do finish with a high
school diploma about 30% better 1.3
million if you have some college so you
go and make maybe you drop out 1.5 a
little better bachelor's degree 2.2
million all right now we're more than
double our high school diploma master's
degree 2.6 doctoral 3.2 and then
professional degree 3.6 million now
that's how much you make over the rest
of your life I would say that that's a
strong point for education so let's move
our graduate up one point now we see
this really high increase in income but
it's not not free so remember this slide
that I showed you earlier the debt that
you take on for student loans you cannot
bankrupt out of which means that until
you die you have to pay it back and they
force you to make that decision when
you're 18 years old and you've never
made a dollar in your life nor can you
comprehend the scope of what
$250,000 of after tax income is and the
interest rates that you're paying when
you make a $250,000 loan out you're not
paying back $250,000 you're paying back
$400 $500,000 in post tax money over the
span of your career and so that leads
naturally to like okay well how is that
going to affect the rest of your life
well look at how earnings actually
increase over time and so this is
important when you look at your actual
life you're going to be saddled with
relatively large payments for a long
period of time and so you can actually
start catching up in your late 30s and
early 40s where earnings begin to spike
when are you starting a family when are
you getting married when are you buying
your first home if that's what you want
to do all here and yet you're still
saddled with that debt that you cannot
get out of and you have very high
interest on to me that's a very strong
point for not going now the median
incomes that I showed you earlier that's
over your lifetime but those don't all
happen at once and often times earning
power and income happen later on in your
career and the higher your degree the
longer it takes to actually get there
and so you can see some of these bottom
rungs more or less stay flat that whole
time whereas some of these other ones
that you have to pay for takes longer in
order to earn back so by the time you're
late 30s early 40 you might be making
more money but you also have the drag of
the debt and the payments and the
interest that you have to carry with you
in the tune of a few hundred, extra does
this differential after tax after
lifestyle and family and house does it
make up the difference you might think
wow then I should not go to college well
the odds are against you in terms of
earning income let's dive in this line
represents bachelor's degree median
lifetime earnings We compare this
visually with each of the other levels
of education so you have a 7.3% chance
of making more than somebody with a
bachelor's degree if you don't graduate
high school the odds aren't in your
favor not to say that you watching this
who's investing in yourself trying to
get educated you're not that 7.3% cuz
you very well might be but statistically
you've got a 1 in 12 shot of just
beating someone who went to college now
if you do graduate you double your
likelihood of beating that person you go
to one in six if you get some college
one in four if you get an associates one
in four is now let's go to Masters you
have a 6 out of 10 shot of making more
money than somebody who just has a
bachelor's if you get a doctoral 7 out
of 10 and then finally a Prof
professional 83% or 8 out of 10 shot of
actually making more money when you do
have more skills you do make more money
the question Still Remains is it worth
it but in my mind this is a clear
argument for more formal education one
point College all the while you're
thinking through this decision you need
to use Warren Buffett's investment
question which is the difference between
what you pay and what you get so if
someone says Hey I want to give you this
Ferrari you might think well obviously I
want to do that well for what price now
if they say for $10,000 that's a great
deal if they say for a million do you
might be like that's a terrible deal and
so it's not about necessarily whether
getting more education makes more money
or not it's just is it worth what it
costs if I said hey I can get you to
make $200,000 a year you might say of
course I'm in but if I said in order to
make that $200,000 a year you need to
pay me $7,000 for the rest of your life
okay okay well all of a sudden the
amount I'm making is significantly less
than that and so you can't take how much
you make without considering how much it
costs I think an important point to make
here is that these are percentages but
it also shows that 27% of people who
have a doctoral degree still don't make
more than people with a bachelor's
degree all that to say these aren't
guarantees the way that they are
purported to be and a lot of college
money goes into advertising that this is
the guaranteed way of moving moving
forward in life but looking at these
stats if you're that one of those five
people or one of those three people
that's below you literally got none of
the upside and all of the downside so
why is there such a disparity between
these earning levels well it also
depends what industry you want to get
into so for example if you want to get
into personal services Blue Collar
health support sales and office the
higher education doesn't make nearly as
much of a difference on the flip side if
you want to get into science technology
you want to get into health professional
so we're talking doctors uh managerial
and professional then it does make a
bigger difference and so part of making
this decision is well what do I want to
do when I grow up so if you think that
you want to go into a very formal career
path you want to be an accountant you
want to be a lawyer you want to be a
doctor then it might make a lot more
sense for you but if you want to be a
salesperson you want to be a marketer do
you want to do any blue collar job any
kind of Home Services things like that
then it probably doesn't make sense for
you and so in my mind that's one point
for both sides so one of the questions I
would be asking is okay well if one out
of eight people who has a high school
degree can beat somebody who has a
college degree over their median
earnings then I'd be like what makes
that one person special we actually
pulled up a great research study that
looked at that exact question which is
how many of these people would have been
successful who went to college already
on their own without going to college
one of the big skews of college is that
people who go to college in general have
more money come from higher
socioeconomic families Etc well if those
people had just gone out on their own
and gone into the professional world
would they have just made the same
amount of money the results might
interest you if you are a white person
or an Asian person you have no value ad
from college if you control for SAT
score socioeconomic status and other
factors that would differentiate people
on the flip side if you are Latino or
you are black college does have a
significant 30 to 40% increase in median
earnings the results like life are a
little bit nuanced it depends on who you
are now I could make an argument or you
might say hey Alex was going to win
either way but what some of you guys
don't know is I went to Vanderbilt and I
graduated magn kumlu that being said
everything that I do in my life today I
didn't learn in college and so the
question is what is it worth the money
the other question is if IID started 4
years earlier would I be further than I
am today so one of the most interesting
statistics I've come across is that
there's one metric above all others that
predicts your earning income better than
anything you want to know what it is
it's not your race it's not your gender
not your IQ think how crazy that is it's
not even your IQ it's the zip code you
were born in my theory on the reason of
why that is and the differential between
races is that when you go to college you
can figuratively change your ZIP code
because you change your environment and
the people you know and more importantly
the people you compare yourself to poor
people can feel rich if they compare
themselves to other poor people but as
soon as you get into a room where
everyone makes 10 times more money than
you all of a sudden you feel like the
poor person and what do you do you
change your behavior College may add
value to people who didn't already get
that value given to them interesting
which makes a strong argument for being
the first person in your family to go to
college because then it actually changes
the trajectory of your Offspring and
your Prodigy and your family tree if
you're not the first person it makes a
lot less of a difference and so the
thing that gets a lot of people to win
at college is the same thing that gets
you to win at business and life and so
the question is is the college really
necessary if you have those
characteristics already in order to get
in like if you got a high enough SAT
score to get into an IV League school
like Harvard Stanford Yale then you
probably are smarter enough to do the
other things without going to Harvard
Stanford and Neale and still make money
as a side note personally I got above
Harvard's GMAT score for business school
I haven't gone to Harvard Business
School but I've done pretty good in
business kind of interesting if I were
to go to Harvard Business School and
then make money afterwards was it
Harvard or was it may and I actually
faced this decision when I was thinking
about going to Harvard and I thought to
myself well do I want to not make money
for 2 years and incur $250,000 of debt
and when I did the dollar and cents for
me going to business school I thought
man why don't I take the
$250,000 and just start a business and
I'll bet that by the end of those two
years I'll have learned more than I did
in business school and I'll graduate The
Game of Life two years ahead and making
more than the median income of somebody
who went to business school and that
ended up being true and so if you want
to get into anything that doesn't have a
formal degree required in order to make
that money then it doesn't make sense
and that's one point for the career so
one of the big things that Pro col
Advocates talk about is the network that
you meet when you're in college and how
much that Alumni network can benefit you
getting a job doing a deal or whatever
it may be in the future and I will put
two strong caveats on that claim number
one is do I think that for $50,000 a
year I could buy into whatever Network I
want to be if people making
significantly more money than me with
skills that I'd like to learn for
$50,000 every single year for four
straight years to me that answer is mood
or even more in favor of just going the
career and if you want to buy a network
then buy a network to me that's an
argument for not going to college if
we're trying to control for the same
money now one of the other points that's
Pro college that is often made is what
about the social experiences you have
the once in A- lifetime opportunity to
be around all people only your age
potentially meet the love of your life
party have lots of fun get dressed up in
toas learn how to beer bong and all of
that stuff for $50,000 a year $1,000 a
week you could party your absolute face
off and make friends with all of these
people in that same period of time now I
would say though it is more difficult to
meet that many people your age in a
professional career than it is to do it
at college and I would say that if
you're looking purely from a fund basis
I'm not going to say real world's going
to beat College
now can you get close with $11,000 a
week you go to Vegas it'll show you a
hell of a time but I would still argue
that from a social perspective those
four years would be more fun the
question is what you're optimizing for
now if you want to say I just want to go
to a resort for 4 years I totally
understand but understand that that's
what you're choosing to buy but if that
is what you want then I would say that
the social aspect is a pro for college
now one of the things worse discussing
is can you get the upside for free now
if you have FAA and you qualify for it
mean you can get financial aid or you
can get grants or you get a merit-based
scholarship for sports or for
scholarship that makes a real difference
because now you're getting all the
upside without having the downside and
if you live within these 24 States you
can actually get a bachelor's degree
whereas the other 26 states in the union
don't actually offer that and if you can
go to college for a bargain then that
might be a great deal and that would be
one point for college I do think that
there are some full price colleges that
even if you had to take loans it would
make sense to go to
if you get into Harvard or you get into
Princeton or you get into Stanford or
Yale or one of the Ivy League schools a
top 20 school in the United States that
everyone recognizes the name I would say
that for how much that will impact your
personal brand that is worth it because
one every single time you walk into a
room people be like oh yeah he went to
Harvard or he went to Yale and that will
immediately shift their perception of
you and the types of jobs and how
quickly you can progress in your career
the second factor is that the people who
go from those colleges become the ruling
class they rule the world they go to the
highest paying jobs the people who
graduate from those schools their median
income I don't know what it is but many
of them are in the tens to 20s to 50s of
millions of dollars per year and so in
those instances if you can get in there
then the Arbitrage of what you pay
versus what you get is still a great
deal now let's look at the lifetime
earnings with a little bit more Nuance
because this is across all degrees in
all schools but I think we can both
agree that all degrees are not created
equal if somebody says hey I have a PhD
from State you versus I have a PhD from
Harvard you could probably bet that that
Harvard PhD is going to be going to top
firms move faster and ultimately just
make more money over the long term they
can also network with other Harvard phds
who get into those great places whereas
that might not be as prevalent and so
the 75th percentile at Harvard for a
bachelor's degree might might be not 3
million but it might be 6 or 10 or 15
million and so in that instance it does
make sense and as much as you're like
man this is a more complex decision yeah
many variables exist and many variables
must be studied Welcome to the Real
World because the ruling class are so
scrutinized for having advantages there
are such generous endowments for those
IV League schools that most people who
don't come from the ruling class can get
significant financial aid for going
there making the trade even more worth
it so if we look at the scoreboard
between college and not College we're
dead even and so let me just give you my
honest opinion right now so I'm looking
down at my life four years in the future
and I see college and I see career me
which one do I choose so if I started
going down the college path if I come
from a wealthier family then I don't get
the benefits of college and I incur the
debt so that might not make sense on the
flip side if I am less fortunate or
coming from a less fortunate family
socioeconomically then I do get a better
benefit from college and I will likely
get some sort of financial aid
increasing the difference between what I
pay and what I get and I have a new
network so my ZIP code improves that
might make a lot of sense for me if I'm
super well off then I already have the
benefits of going to college and I might
as well start my career with those
benefits already not incur debt and make
four years more income and four years
further in my career path provided I
don't want to do science technology
doctor lawyer accountant stuff if I'm
lower socioeconomic status then I might
not have the same benefit and I might
find myself in the bottom part of that
Circle that represents the statistics
not to say that you're not the one of
eight people who can earn more it's just
less likely so given those variables
where do we go from here if I came from
a a lower educated lower socioeconomic
family and get financial aid
significantly I would say 50% or more of
that tuition I would say go to college
you pay less for what you get and you
get more than anyone else does on the
flip side and this is counterintuitive
if you already come from a highly
educated family and you have higher
socioeconomic status and you're not
going to get favorable financial terms
for paying for school it makes less
sense for you to go the counterintuitive
thing here is that the rich families the
better off families are the ones that
encourage their kids to go to college
the most I would even say they encourage
them they expect it they demand it it's
assumed it's the default choice this box
is already checked for them at Birth if
you get no benefit from college and it
cost you money and four years of
otherwise Career Development then you
shouldn't do it the big caveat off the
top is if you want to go into one of
those careers that requires a degree it
requires a degree it it is what it is
but I will say this if you don't have a
plan for what you want to do with your
life don't expect that $200,000 in four
years is somehow going to give you a
plan you just need to confront the fact
that right when you graduate you're
still going to be looking at life with
all the directions coming from your feet
and being like well what should I do now
because I can promise you even if you
fell in love with a class there's no
career path that's the class and so it
doesn't even mean anything to get good
to that and so once you get into the
real world you're like well I loved
biology well unless you're going to be a
scientist or you're going to be a
physician you're probably going to go
into HR it makes way more sense to
actually learn what the Departments of a
business are and what those roles entail
on a day-to-day basis and think well
these are the types of things I like if
I like talking to people I could be a
recruiter for a company if I like
talking to people I could be in sales at
somebody who employs almost a thousand
people now between our portfolio
companies we don't care at all what
someone's degree is you know what we do
care about
experience so if I had a 4-year college
graduate who comes out with a Philosophy
degree and I've got somebody who's been
in sales for four years and didn't have
a degree and they're the same age who do
you think I'm picking for the sales job
the guy who's been in sales for four
years if I were deciding between going
to college and not going to college this
is what I'd be thinking about now if
you're not going to college and you've
made that decision let's talk about how
to actually maximize that path number
one is that you are still prioritizing
education you're just not prioritizing
formal education so you should
absolutely take money take time and
spend the majority of your day trying to
learn if you play video games all day
and you just watch Netflix and you smoke
weed in your parents basement you're
going to be the seven out of eight who
lose but if you are the type of person
who can work all day and work on
themselves and get experience in the
real world then you can learn at your
job all day get paid to learn take that
money spend it on learning more in the
evenings and 4 years from now you will
be so much better equipped than anybody
who has graduated four years in a formal
degree who just knows how to shotgun a
beer really fast I will tell you how
I've learned everything outside of
school I pay people who already have the
skill by the hour to learn now if I
can't afford them I will see if I can
buy a course or a book or watch their
videos or whatever it is but if they
don't have any of that stuff and you're
just saying man I really want to learn
how to do storage units from this guy
well then you can ask to pay for 1 hour
a week to learn what to do and I can
promise you entrepreneur and people who
have skills are always happy to help
people who take initiative there's
nothing that fills someone's heart more
speaking from personal experience of
somebody who asks you for advice and
then executes on it and as long as you
do that you will have more help than you
know what to do with start one or two
steps ahead of where you're at pay to
learn the skills and then take one or
two steps whether you're taking this
path or you're taking this path you have
to choose to invest in your ability to
learn so that you can earn in the future
more than you are everything that you
make in the first four years of your
career is not what you're trying to get
rich on it's what you're trying to get
smart on and the fact that you get paid
for it is just bonus so don't get your
ego caught up in the fact that you're
making $30,000 a year or $40,000 a year
or minimum wage I started at minimum
wage after having a white collar job for
two years and getting above Harvard's
mid score and so you have to take a
slice of Humble Pie to realize that I
might have been really good as a
Management Consultant but I didn't know
[__] about running a gym and so not
coming in pretending like you know
something that you don't and being
willing to accept the fact that someone
who might be less educated or less
polished than you still knows more now
if you get into the IV League school
then by all means like I said go but if
you don't get into one of those schools
and you're just into the the middle of
the pack that costs too much and doesn't
give you anything extra then I think
that you need to pull up to the table
put the napkin in your collar and take a
slice of Humble Pie and realize that you
don't know everything and you have to be
willing to suck and you also have to be
willing to be doubted by your family
because they probably won't agree with
this decision because they're going to
think well this worked for me my life is
great and I want the same for you but
remember they're doing this out of love
for you because they want you to win but
you just have to explain to them I want
me to win too and I think times have
changed when they came out hierarchy and
tenure mattered a ton and pedigree
whereas today because everyone has equal
access to information for free on the
internet and you can learn more on
YouTube than you can from most colleges
you don't need what once was required so
big picture you don't need to stress
you're going to win either way if you're
a winner this will probably just get you
there faster with less debt on the flip
side if you are born in a bad zip code
you have a family that the majority of
them has not gone to school or any kind
of formal education and you don't saddle
your family or yourself with debt in
order to go to school it almost always
makes sense to go to school because all
you're doing is you're getting a
different network of people you will
then change the trajectory of your
progeny your family tree that comes
after you and all you do is you start 4
years later and again you have all the
earning potential benefits of going and
getting a bachelor's degree but without
all the costs and you got a real value
ad from college whereas somebody who
started with an advantage doesn't and so
in that sense it absolutely does make
sense to do that I'm going to as many
credits as I can and I'm doing that so I
can meet as many people as humanly
possible all right so that's where you
sign for the Social Clubs sign up for
the sororities and fraternities go to
all the things that you can your Lux
surface area will increase with the
amount of people that you expose
yourself to and will also introduce you
to a lot of diversity of opinion and if
you're going to college cuz we want to
change your environment and change what
you compare yourself to then the best
thing to do is get exposed to a lot of
different things and if you find
yourself in a position where you have a
hard time not partying as much not to
say that you can't party have fun but if
you're slacking at school you're paying
to go to school it is your job to learn
and you need to treat it like that
you're paying not even getting paid
you're paying $1,000 a week to get
educated and you're going to have to
make up that ,000 later on with interest
and so you better [__] learn
something while you're there and so the
idea of the fifth year senior and taking
12 credits a semester the bare minimum
required to be a full-time student what
a joke take 18 take 21 credits and do it
in four years you can gra graduate with
a double degree I just graduated in
three I cut a year off right if you can
go to summer school you can also save
money and you can still get the same
benefits and so you can graduate in 2
years or 3 years if you absolutely
hustle your ass off because you are a
professional student act like one the
tldr is in either of these paths you are
choosing to learn not earn the money
goes in different directions but that is
the objective and in both of these
career paths objective number one is
being a professional and you're either
being a professional student or you're
being being a professional student that
just happens to get paid for it but in
either situation learning comes above
everything else the side benefits are
that you'll meet a few more people and
your party a little harder the side
benefits here that you're not going to
go in debt and you're going to get paid
to do it I want you to know that I am
more impartial than probably anyone else
in your life and I say that because I
don't know I don't know you and I don't
know anyone else in your life now they
will get status based on their friend
group who are older might not understand
stuff like this video and so they want
you to do that because one it probably
comes from a good place but two because
they're afraid of their downside of what
if you become a failure but by the way
you can become a failure if you go to
college too so the one thing that you
can do to guarantee this is that you
have to decide for yourself number one
and number two is that either of these
paths is education and you have to
understand that you're not getting into
the workforce to go make money you're
getting into the workforce to learn
better more relevant skills and just
happen to get paid for it as long as you
keep that clear and that you're going to
stay disciplined about it because you're
not going to be more necessarily
disciplined when there's tons of naked
girls and parties around you and some
I'm sold on College by that alone I get
it but I promise there's plenty of time
for both send this to anyone who is
debating this decision right now thank
you for playing the game of one of zero
I hope you win